European Union foreign ministers have
been meeting in the Ukrainian capital
keev in their first summit outside the
Block's borders the eu's foreign policy
Chief Joseph Burell described Ukraine as
a future member of the union he said
they were meeting in keev to show
solidarity with the Ukrainian people Zay
mravi joins us live from lub in Ukraine
zann the symbolism there very strong to
see eu's the eu's top diplomats in
Ukraine what are they
saying
that is exactly right this is certainly
one for the history books ke has long
been a place since the War Began for
Turn Style diplomacy we've seen senior
leaders defense ministers everyone come
through just in the last week but this
is certainly uh one of the largest
meetings if not the most significant
we've seen perhaps since the War Began
27 all 27 members of the European Union
only three of them sent uh lower ranking
officials most of them sending their
senior most foreign diplomats uh to key
for this meeting and perhaps the largest
show of European commitment to Ukraine
Joseph Burl saying that the war in the
Russian war in Ukraine is an existential
threat not just to Ukraine but to the
European project and making it clear as
he has said before that Ukraine's future
is in the European Union and this is
perhaps the clearest symbol uh of that
happening the first meeting happening
outside the EU in keev now they say that
they will be discussing increased
military aid to Ukraine uh they are
expecting to come up with the new plan
going forward for 2024 and 2025 by the
end of this year and they will be
discussing that military aid as well as
all forms of Civilian Aid to the country
in meetings we're expecting a press
conference in coming hours with some
sort of announcement and we know that
they'll be talking about new plans for
things like artillery ammunition
crucially air defense something that
zalinsky has been President Vladimir
zinski give Ukraine has been saying he
needs more of from uh supporters of the
war of Ukraine's war effort and he will
also they will also be discussing
training now the bulk of Ukrainian
troops being trained militarily uh for
all kinds of tactics uh uh air defense
on military aircraft as well as tanks
are being trained in the EU uh there'll
also be crucially discussing local
domestic defense production that Europe
has promised Ukraine to help to
modernize and develop here in in the
country Zay this war started a year and
a half ago why are they doing this
now well timing and geography timing and
location are are crucial in politics
having this in keev is obviously very
symbolic but the timing it comes just a
day after the United States Congress
passed a bill and removed Ukraine from
its latest spending bill it also comes
just shortly after Slovakia got a
pro-russian government in place
bolstering Hungary that was also there
uh there was already quite against uh EU
policy when it comes to Ukraine uh we're
also seeing that this is just a weeks
after a great deal of Discord between
Ukraine and several EU countries with
regards to Ukrainian grain that was
ending up on markets pitting them
against one of their closest allies in
the war Poland so this really symbolize
at a crucial moment that if there was
ever any question about uh allies
wavering on their support for Ukraine
this illustrates to Ukraine to the EU
crucially to Moscow as well that the EU
the majority of EU countries speak in
one voice when it comes to supporting
Ukraine in this war for the long term
Zan mravi reporting from Ukraine thank
you very much